[Music]
i'm thinking about this all wrong
we don't need to make me taller we just
have to make everyone else
shorter so let's electrocute everybody
else's legs
three two one cheese
but michael it kind of seems like you're
just coming up with another excuse to
tase people yes
i used to love laser tag as a kid but
now it's gotten boring and we gotta make
it interesting again
with tasers
have you ever thought to yourself gee i
wish i had a robot that could shoot
lasers
into my eyes well i sure have uh that's
why i built one
you know room but cleans your house
how likely would it be to adopt this
into your household
[Music]
in a very popular corner of twitch sits
a channel belonging to a mad
scientist named michael reeves it ain't
doing [ __ ]
okay controller's not doing [ __ ]
the guy is an overnight twitch sensation
literally
michael averaged almost 25 000 viewers
on his first stream
and averages almost 15 000 viewers on
every stream
since then it's offline tv's michael
reeves
has started streaming tonight
yes after five days of streaming michael
actually surpassed my sub count
ah viewers can't get enough of his crazy
inventions and down to earth personality
but
to understand why fans want so much more
of michael reeves
we need to rewind to a platform where
his content is much less frequent
youtube
i know what's good my dudes for those of
you who haven't seen his youtube videos
michael reeves is somewhere between an
insane inventor
and a comic book super villain most
people in your line of work are trying
to solve problems but you're working to
create them does it concern you that
you're currently on a direct path of
being a super villain
no no dude you're like you like syndrome
from [ __ ]
yeah i'm actually like syndrome he is he
was just talking about making a driving
kill everyone's trying to be tony stark
and [ __ ] i just want to be the best
jimmy neutron i can [ __ ] be in his
life
and it's hard to call his skills
anything less than impressive
i mean to begin with he taught himself
how to code while still in high school
the reason i got into coding was because
like i wasn't
very good at anything in high school so
i was like i need a job after this or
i'm gonna be homeless
right so i just like really stuck with
one thing
really didn't like it at first but then
like as you improve at something i think
it's really hard to dislike something
when you get good at it
yeah and then from there bored with his
job working for the government
reeves decided to make a dumb robot for
fun and then he uploaded it to youtube
have you ever thought to yourself gee i
wish i had a robot that could shoot
lasers
into my eyes well i sure have everyone
has
it's an age-old question is there a god
what is the meaning of life and
can i have a robot that recognizes my
face and shoots me with lasers in the
eyeball
that's why i built one and [ __ ] ever
since then he's become an
expert in making dumb dangerous and
hilarious mechanical monstrosities
and now dick gun or youtube buddy gun
[ __ ] whatever squirt boy 9000 is the
final solution to all of your sleep
deprivation problems
it's got all the premium features that
you want it's
got the jagged edges it's got the
exposed 120 volt wire terminals
it's got the liquid stored next to the
electricity
trigger miyomo because god has been dead
for a very long time
but while his youtube content was
insanely popular
it came at a price time see making
screaming roombas or trigger me elmos
takes a lot of time
meaning they only got new content every
month or so
and as you can guess fans wanted more
michael
robots or otherwise he eventually made
his way from hawaii to los angeles where
he collaborated and
tested his new inventions on other
popular content creators
3 2 1
[Music]
while he was killing it on youtube
michael reeves didn't really enter the
world of twitch
until he crossed paths with a certain
content house hi my name is michael
reeves and i'm joining offline tv
and as you can probably guess he had
some plans for his new roommates
i just really needed like test subjects
for videos and now i have
what [ __ ] six seven eight of those
[ __ ] do you know how many people i
can taste
it didn't take long for michael reeves
to become everyone's favorite pop-in
guest whenever one of his roommates
streamed he created clippable moments
whenever he was on camera
[ __ ] you i'm thirsty
[Applause]
but while doing offline tv content and
being a repeat guest on other streams
was a good start
it wasn't enough for fans of michael
reeves they wanted more
so after months of begging he eventually
took the plunge and started his own
twitch stream
hi now i stream and
i'm playing minecraft because my friends
wanted to play minecraft
streaming was just fun for michael
something to do while he spent
a month building his next chaotic
invention
i didn't come into it with the idea that
i want it to be more lucrative than
youtube i just want to make like
because i make a youtube video like once
every month or two now so
like i need to like make something else
that isn't just that
so twitch streaming is the thing i
suppose
and as you could expect those inventions
spilled over to a stream
and they were something straight out of
a jimmy neutron episode
okay dude
[Laughter]
this is michael reeves we're talking
about the mad scientist of twitch
you think he would just stream normally
even his
sub button is very him this is it
that was one second you [ __ ] turn the
drill on when you stop
it works you turn the girl on when he's
up
again
you [ __ ] did it we [ __ ] did it
when you summed it it turns the goddamn
drill off
but that's not to say his streams are
just some weird tech fever dream
the guy's entertaining even when he's
just hanging out playing minecraft or
valor
[Music]
while his content is definitely unique
for the platform
michael reeves as a personality is right
at home on twitch
and now thanks to streaming fans get to
consistently see reeves doing what he
does
best being himself who's offline tv i
don't like oh they're the one with the
dog that pisses in your cup
the pissing dog that pisses in your cup
of parties it's those guys
oh are those guys of course i know those
guys
they're the ones who taught the boston
dynamics dog to feel pain when you
yell at it i know this sounds crazy but
i'm kind of